president Trump's impeachment trial will
come to an end Wednesday and the
president is likely to be acquitted his
campaign spent ten million dollars on
re-election ads like this one during the
Superbowl which show he is already
looking forward to November we show Jang
is at the White House we shall what's
the White House's strategy this week
oh good morning Anthony and good morning
to everybody President Trump will try to
move forward and deliver a quote very
very positive message during tomorrow
night's State of the Union address
senior administration officials say
there will be a strong focus on the
economy and they won't reveal whether
the president will even mention his
impeachment trial but during an
interview last night he did not hold
back I mean my family suffered because
of all of this in a traditional
pre-super Bowl presidential interview
President Trump said impeachment has
taken a toll and doubted whether he can
work with Democrats going forward I see
the hatred I see the dilemma they don't
care about fairness they don't care
about lying so I'm not sure that they
can do it to be honest mr. Trump has
always insisted he did nothing wrong
when he asked Ukraine's President to
investigate political rival Joe Biden
now several Republicans are publicly
disagreeing I think it was wrong
inappropriate was the way I'd say
improper crossing the line but not wrong
enough they say to lose his job does it
come to the point of removing a
president from office I don't believe
this does on Face the Nation House
Intelligence Chairman Adam Schiff said
the explosive claims by john bolton mean
impeachment is not the end the truth
will come out is will continue to come
out in leaks of his unpublished
manuscript bolton has not only said that
President Trump linked the aid to
Ukraine with the Biden investigations
but he also claims White House Counsel
Pat's at Bologna was aware on Friday
just hours after the Senate voted
against new witnesses and documents the
Justice Department revealed there are 24
redacted emails related to the
president's decision-making
freezing military aid to Ukraine that
shows you the lengths to which the
president's lawyers are going to cover
this up this week we will hear closing
arguments and speeches from senators who
will finally have a chance to talk and
those Republicans who were on the fence
about voting to block witnesses will
likely defend their decision before the
final vote to clear President Trump on
Wednesday Gail thank you very much
weecha CBS News plans to bring you
today's Senate and Pietschmann closing
arguments in a special report we will
also carry president Trump State of the
Union address and the Democrats response
that's tomorrow night at 9:00 Eastern
8:00 central right here on CBS
you